in an interview that aired earlier today
President Trump claimed President Andrew
Jackson could have prevented the Civil
War even though President Andrew Jackson
died more than a decade before the civil
war began Trump also asked quote why was
there the Civil War why could that not
have been worked out now critics are
saying this demonstrates Trump's
ignorance of US history but Trump is
doubling down on his claims even going
as far as quickly releasing just moments
ago this clip from an upcoming
documentary that he has produced the
civil war no one knows why this big
happened but what a disaster the year
was either 1975 or 1985 some say it
never happened at all but one thing we
know is trouble was brewing while things
were getting pretty tense between the
North and the South the east and the
West were wisely sitting this what
happened whatever caused this thing it
really dragged out who knows maybe it
was the YouTube soldiers who were being
paid to fight by George Soros and The
Huffington Post another reason this
thing went on for so long is most of the
fake media coverage of the war was just
drawings back then the soldiers had to
stand around for days posing for
drawings just a huge pain in the ass
I say draw them after the battle when
they're dead and when we think this
thing could have been prevented by a
great president like Andrew Jackson or
his younger brother mr. October Reggie
Jackson
pretty good let's say b-plus
you